un chéquier d'une valeur de 100 euros à
échanger contre une série de 10 heures
de formation voilà ce que propose le
Pass numérique sur le principe des
tickets restaurants il permet au
bénéficiaires de payer totalement ou en
partie des cours numérique auprès de
structures spécialisées on a différents
l'obligation d'aller sur le site
internet pour faire des démarches
publiques donc il répond vraiment à
destination de trois publics les gens en
difficulté sociale les gens alors là
vous appelez les seniors même c'est les
seigneurs qui sont très bons pour aller
sur internet et également les personnes
qui ont des difficultés qui ont juste
pas d'outils numériques
déploie le Pass numérique dans les
départements des Hauts-de-Seine et des
Yvelines depuis septembre 2021 au centre
socio-culturel yaick Noah à Asnières des
ateliers d'initiation et de
perfectionnement avec des professionnels
sont proposés Anne d'eau et Françoise
ils prennent part une fois par semaine
j'arrivais à la retraite et que je
savais que j'étais pas avant tout
informatique j'allais au bureau chercher
des papiers mais plus qu'on a vu déjà
après le covid 19 que tous les bureaux
sont fermés Françoise tu peux un peu
nous dire à quoi ressemblerait un mot de
passe sécurisé pour la création des
alors il faut il faut que ce mot de
passe soit composé de majuscule de
chiffres c'est quelque chose qui est
devenu important pour notre quotidien de
pouvoir
savoir
gérer l'informatique aller sur le site
chercher des informations la technique
on nous la donne pas c'est pas inné et
notre génération n'est pas du tout née
avec ça j'ai un pc chez moi j'ai une
tablette j'ai un smartphone mais je
bidouille et je il y a des choses que je
ne sais pas faire et que j'aimerais
faire effectuer une démarche en ligne
protéger ses données personnelles ou
encore naviguer sur le web les cours ont
un seul objectif mené petit à petit vers
l'autonomie là on est plutôt face à une
fracture numérique de premier degré qui
correspond à un non accès à la formation
et une fracture numérique de second
degré qui correspond à un non accès à
l'usage avec beaucoup de crainte et
beaucoup de peur qu'il faut aussi lever
depuis son déploiement quasiment 200
formations ont été données en France 13
millions de Français demeurent encore
éloignés du numérique